[Música]
la vida es un sueño
esta afirmación no siempre nos resulta
fácil de expresar
de hecho en momentos difíciles le
echaríamos una buena riña a la vida por
traernos lo que tenemos ante nosotros y
que no quisiéramos que estuviera
sucediendo
sin embargo incluso en estas situaciones
que desafían nuestras fuerzas la vida no
regala el tiempo y la capacidad para
pensar y poder crear un nuevo estado de
bienestar y abundancia
y qué hacemos normalmente con un regalo
por recibirlo agradecerlo tener la
intención clara de disfrutarlo al máximo
y siempre que sea posible
y compartirlo
así que esa es mi intención vivir la
vida como un regalo
porque tener una intención clara
orientada a crear bienestar y abundancia
a generar armonía y prosperidad en
nuestra vida es la brújula que nos
permite definir nuestra dirección
nuestra hoja de ruta y a partir de ahí
fijar nuestros objetivos por eso hoy
quiero invitarte a pensar durante unos
segundos cuál es tu intención en esta
etapa de tu vida
la tienes te apuntas a vivir la vida
como un regalo
además de tener una intención clara para
avanzar hacia nuestras metas necesitamos
generar emociones elevadas como el amor
la bondad la pasión estas emociones nos
dan la fuerza para perseguir nuestros
sueños
nos permiten disfrutar de los buenos
momentos y nos hacen resilientes en las
situaciones difíciles
de modo que yo decido conscientemente
generar en mi vida una emoción que me
impulsa que es la alegría de vivir
por las mañanas cuando me despierto
elijo pensar qué alegría tengo un nuevo
día por delante
con desafíos y retos por supuesto pero
también cargado de nuevas oportunidades
quizá ahora te preguntes si ya ha
definido una intención clara que indica
la dirección que tengo que seguir si ya
estoy generando emociones elevadas que
me dan la fuerza que necesito ahora como
paso de la intención a la acción para
alcanzar mis metas pues hoy estoy aquí
para impulsar t a lograrlo para ello
quiero compartir contigo tres claves
conocer cuidar y crear
estas son tres áreas muy amplias de
desarrollo conforman una metodología de
entrenamiento para crear bienestar y
abundancia por lo que ahora te invito a
empezar con tres sencillas acciones que
puedes empezar ya puedes empezar a
ponerlas en práctica ya la primera
acción
conocer tus talentos
cuáles son tus talentos
todos tenemos recursos para brillar tú
tienes algo que te hace especial que
cuando lo descubres y lo compartes te da
confianza y te permite definir tu
propósito de vida tú tienes capacidades
y talentos
que te hacen un ser único e irrepetible
capaz de crear bienestar y abundancia
para ti y para todos los demás para tu
entorno
se curioso descubre cuáles son tus
talentos los mayores talentos que puedas
tener y no piensa solamente en el arte
hay muchos talentos escondidos
descúbrelo si cuando lo consigas utiliza
los para crecer compártelos con bondad y
brilla
y no estoy hablando de brillar para
deslumbrar a nadie estoy hablando de
brillar para impulsar a otras personas a
que logren sus metas con sus propios
recursos
y al mismo tiempo que estás haciendo
aquello para lo que tienes un don
especial
mantén una atenta observación
a conocer los talentos de todas las
personas que te rodean porque todos esos
talentos unidos os pueden hacer llegar
más allá de lo que nunca hubieras
imaginado
la segunda clave es cuidar cuidar tu
lenguaje
cuidar tu lenguaje significa utilizar
palabras que impulsen y motiven no
palabras que frenen y desmotiven
qué significa esto pues que cuando tú
entrenas tu lenguaje para utilizar
palabras que empoderan lo que estás
haciendo se elaborando pensamientos
motivadores estos pensamientos provocan
sentimientos y emociones elevados que a
su vez se traducen en una forma de
actuar como pues más eficiente y más
proactiva luego los resultados estarán
ahí
además cuando tú te hablas con cariño y
con respeto
empiezas a quererte más
cuando tú te quieres más empieza a
querer cuidarte
y eres consciente de la importancia de
vivir el momento presente este este es
el momento esta es nuestra vida nuestra
vida está aquí la importancia de vivir
el momento presente de llevar una
alimentación saludable de practicar
ejercicio regular de descansar y cuando
comienzas a llevarlo a cabo cada vez te
sientes mejor
además cuando te tú te quieres más que
pasa pues que empiezas a querer más a
los demás ya querer cuidarlos empezando
por utilizando un lenguaje que les haga
sentir bien
date cuenta que solamente cuidando el
lenguaje estás impactando directamente
en las consecuencias de tu vida y estás
creando bienestar y abundancia
la tercera clave es crear
y crear hábitos saludables
piensa durante un momento que hábito
saludable puedes empezar a crear hoy
que vaya a tener impacto potente y
beneficioso en tu vida
yo te invito a crear el hábito de
agradecer
agradecer la abundancia que hay ante ti
todas las cosas buenas que hay en tu
vida aunque haya cosas que te duelan que
es un hábito un hábito es una acción que
repetida en el tiempo en condiciones
similares se convierte en automática
entonces cómo podemos crear el hábito de
agradecer pues como todos los hábitos
saludables con entrenamiento y con
práctica mucha práctica así que cada vez
que la vida te traiga algo que te haga
sentir bien agradece lo a raudales
de igual modo cuando la vida te trae a
te ponga ante una situación difícil
puedes decidir agradecer el tener
recursos para afrontarlas y también
tener personas en las que confiar en
esas situaciones retadoras
y agradecer lo que nos permite
es tener mayor bienestar porque cuando
agradecemos nuestro cuerpo nos responde
con mayor bienestar y al mismo tiempo
nuestra mente está más calmada está
motivada y está enfocada en que en lo
que va bien en lo bueno en la abundancia
ya partir de ahí podemos conectar con la
situación que tenemos y si nos duele
podemos ser resilientes y transformar
eso en amor que nos dé fuerza para crear
cosas buenas
agradece continuamente sinceramente y de
corazón que lotes frenen agradece sin
parar porque porque eso es bueno para ti
cuando lo estás haciendo te genera
bienestar pero también estás generando
bienestar a tu alrededor y adivina estás
creando bienestar y abundancia de nuevo
quiero terminar con una cita del
filósofo español
ortega y gasset que dice así
el ser humano no es un participio es un
gerundio y así es tu vosotros como ser
humano no sois un participio porque no
estáis terminados finalizados concluidos
funcionamos funcionas como un gerundio
porque siempre estás cambiando siempre
estás creando evolucionando y creciendo
y para impulsar t a seguir creciendo ya
disfrutar del regalo de la vida quiero
compartir hoy estas tres claves que te
invito a practicar conocer tus talentos
cuidar tu lengua un lenguaje y crear el
hábito de agradecer y si te funcionan te
animo a compartirlas para poder generar
entre todos y para todos
bienestar y abundancia muchas gracias
[Música]